sciences bonjour et bienvenue dans cette
audience qui aujourd'hui devrait plaire
aux amoureux dédié aux les dinosaures ce
sont les meilleurs amis des petits ils
ont bercé notre enfance était beaucoup
de trous dans notre porte monnaie
mais avant de devenir une véritable
machine à fric les dinosaures c'est quoi
au juste
je vois déjà se dessiner le sourire béat
fastoche c'est des bestioles dont le nom
finit par or
eh bien c'est faux la terminaison or qui
vient du latin au russe signifie
reptiles et peut donc en théorie se
retrouver dans le nom de n'importe quel
reptiles mais en pratique il arrive
aussi que des mammifères comme la
baleine fossiles basile other se
retrouve avec un an terminé par aux
russes ou aussi le pokémon bulbes azor
ou le nabuchodonosor d'ailleurs il
existe aussi les dinosaures dont le
nombre se termine pas par hasard tels
que leurs abdos don ou le comme sonia
tus et célèbre triceratops iguanodon
dipl depuis ce velociraptor et bien
d'autres une autre suggestion peut-être
bien tenté mais contrairement à ce que
les médias nous vendent régulièrement il
n'y a pas que la taille qui compte m'en
direz tant
il existait deux tout petits dinosaures
comme le comme sonia tueuse par exemple
et même les plus gros dinosaures
n'étaient pas gros tu te laves bon temps
en temps une approche sous un angle un
peu plus scientifique
ce sont des reptiles disparu il ya 65
millions d'années on doit s'approcher là
non certes mais ce n'est pas encore ça
les dinosaures ne sont pas les seuls
vrais petits as être un peu enflammé ya
65 millions d'années de nombreuses
espèces de serpents de lézards mais
aussi de crocodiles et de tortues se
sont éteintes faire de la grande crise
crétacé tertiaire il ya 65 millions
d'années
bon d'accord on a bien fait le tour des
réponses fausses mais finalement qu'est
ce qui fait qu une bestiole plus qu'une
autre est un dinosaure et bien entre
autres caractères du squelette d'un
dinosaure éteint et ils ont les pattes
sont bien à droite sous le corps et
soutiennent le poids de l'animal comme
des piliers on retrouve cette
caractéristique aussi bien chez les
dinosaures carnivores bipèdes que chez
les herbivores quadrupèdes et les autres
et ils comme les tortues les gecko et
autres lézards les crocodiles et les
varans de komodo ne sont pas des
dinosaures car ils n'ont pas cette
caractéristique fondamentale que tous
les dinosaures on a été de leurs
ancêtres communs exactement eu leurs
membres font saillie
sur le côté du corps et non en dessous
donc si on se résume ça veut dire que ni
les ptérosaures ni les reptiles marins
qui vivait pourtant la même époque que
les dinosaures et ont disparu en même
temps ce sont des dinosaures
tout à fait car l'absence de membres en
pilier montre qu'il ne partage pas
d'ancêtres communs direct avec les
dinosaures
tout est une affaire de famille si vous
n'avez pas ce petit plus unique qui
démontre que vous êtes un descendant de
l'ancêtre commun des dinosaures alors
vous ne pouvez pas être classée comme
étant un dinosaure
c'est comme un laissez passer ou un test
de paternité mais les mammifères alors
ils ont les membres droit sous le corps
non a certes oui mais pour des tas
d'autres raisons les mammifères ne font
pas partie de la série des reptiles
notamment parce qu'ils n'ont pas des
cayes corner mais des poils donc pour
être un dinosaure il faut être et un
reptile et à voir les membres droit sous
le corps comme les oiseaux car les
oiseaux on n'est pas bien droit de sous
le corps comme des dinosaures et ils ont
des écailles des reptiles mais attend
personne ne sait si les dinosaures
avaient des écailles en fait si on le
sait très bien même car de nombreux
possible de potes dinosaures sont
connues y compris en france
dans ce cas je m'incline les oiseaux
sont bel et bien des dinosaures
effectivement les oiseaux descendent
directement du groupe des dinosaures
carnivores nommer les théropodes
évidemment rome ne s'est pas fait en un
jour et de nombreux intermédiaires
structuraux sont connus comme
l'archaeopteryx par exemple sa coupe et
si c'est le cas c'est que vous aviez
sûrement d'état l'a priori sur les
dinosaures le premier temps qu'un
dinosaure par définition devrait être
énorme
pourtant comme nous l'avons dit les
dinosaures ne sont pas tous groupes
beaucoup d'entre eux étaient petits
comme le combinat tus par exemple mais
évidemment comme ils sont petits est la
presse en parle beaucoup moins le
deuxième est que les dinosaures sont
souvent dépeints comme des animaux lourd
lent incapable de se mouvoir sur la
terre ferme ou même rapidement mais il
s'agit d'une image d'epinal nevers le
tout début du siècle dernier et qui
s'est répandue comme une traînée de
poudre
car elle mettait l'accent sur notre
supériorité face aux dinosaures
mais cette façon de représenter les
dinosaures n'étaient pas celles du
pionnier de l'étude des dinosaures le
fondateur de ce mot richard owen
lorsqu'il a reconstruit pour la première
fois des dinosaures pour l'exposition du
crystal palace vers la fin du 19e siècle
ces créatures seront construites en
action l'oeil vif posture érigé
supportant leurs corps massif sur la
terre ferme et non pas dans l'eau
quoique un peu démodé ces
reconstitutions n'en reste pas moins
remarquable étant donné les
connaissances de l'époque
mais surtout elle témoigne de ce qu owen
imaginez les dinosaures comme des
animaux puissant et vivace l'un des
principaux préjugés concernant les
dinosaures tient au fait que le son
représente souvent les dinosaures comme
ça elise oiseaux comme ça mais les
oiseaux ne sont pas toujours aussi
mignon prenez par exemple l'autruche et
le casoar ou mieux encore regardons le
titanic le célèbre oiseau possible
mangeurs de chevaux beaucoup moins
mignon n'est ce pas et que dire du non
moins célèbre gast ornis lui aussi est
énorme
toutefois il semblerait d'après ses
empreintes de pas qui n'est pas été
pourvus des grosses griffes qui lui
auraient été nécessaires pour chasser il
paraît même qu'il aurait était
végétarien alors d'anciens à quoi lui
servait cette énorme beck est peut-être
servait-il au mal qu'on s'attirer les
faveurs des femelles qui sait ou plus
simplement à casser les noix de coco des
études sont en cours
affaire à suivre donc donc les oiseaux
n'ont pas toujours étaient mignons mais
surtout ce qui nous tient généralement
le plus à coeur c'est l'image des
dinosaures théropodes tel que nous l'a
vendu les médias à savoir des êtres
visqueux cruel plein dedans et de
griffes
concernant les griffes les dinosaures
maman bien sûr pas le monopole mais
surtout certains oiseaux en possèdent
c'est notamment le cas de l'eau at in
and oiseaux d'amérique du sud qui
lorsqu'il est encore plus un possède
deux petites griffes qui disparaît
ensuite plus tard vous noterez la
ressemblance frappante entre la main de
poussins i was in est celle d'un
dinosaure théropode concernant les dents
et bien bas tous les dinosaures
théropodes n'en avait pas
comme par exemple le vix raptor il est
bien connu que les poules non plus n'ont
pas de dents ou tout du moins non plus
c'est en tout cas ce qu'ont montré
plusieurs équipe de généticiens qui ont
réussi par les manipulations de l'adn à
faire repousser de petites dents sur des
embryons de poulet ils ont montré ainsi
que le gène des dents n'étaient pas
totalement absent chez les oiseaux il
que simplement au hall 2 me d'ailleurs
de nombreuses offres aussi comme
l'espère ornis posséder encore des dents
pour ce qui est de la viscosité de leur
peau on sait que les dinosaures avaient
des écailles
mais l'une des plus grandes surprises de
ces dernières années a été de découvrir
qu'elle avait aussi des plumes
aujourd'hui suffisamment de gisements
différents dans le monde ont fourni un
assez grand nombre de spécimens portant
des plumes ou des empreintes d'insertion
de plumes
que ce soit en espagne en allemagne en
amérique ou encore en asie et s'est
aussi penchée dinosaure herbivore que
chez des dinosaures carnivores
ainsi on est à peu près sûr que tous ou
presque tous les dinosaures avaient des
plumes ou du moins quelque chose qui
devait y ressembler et même le
tyrannosaure en avait c'est en tout cas
ce que révèlent des fossiles trouvés en
chine appartenant à ses très proches
parents et qui dit plume dip ou puces et
autres parasites du plumage et ceux qui
ont été retrouvées fossilisés sont
énormes de la taille des doigts ces
puits ne servait évidemment pas à voler
imaginez le t-rex d'attendre ces petits
brins pour décoller d'une falaise ce
serait grotesque on pense plutôt que ces
plumes d'aspect simple du ltte zhu
filamenteuses devait servir comme chez
les poussins à maintenir la température
du corps argumentant au passage dans la
faveur de l'hypothèse selon laquelle les
dinosaures étaient des animaux à sang
chaud
elle devait aussi être très coloré et
servir de signal de reconnaissance ou
pour les parades nuptiales encore que
pour ce qui est de la couleur les
techniques actuelles basées sur les
rayons x ne permettent de détecter que
le noir et le blanc et les pigments
responsable des nuances de rouge
d'orange et de jaune mais chez les
oiseaux actuels les couleurs chatoyantes
comme le verre ou le bleu par exemple ne
sont pas dues à des pigments et non
elles sont dues à la structure
microscopique même des plumes qui
filtrent réfracte et reflète une façon
bien particulière la lumière ces
phénomènes optiques sont dans l'état
actuel des connaissances encore assez
mal compris celle actuelle alors celle
fossiles terminons enfin si vous le
voulez bien par la cruauté légendaire
des dinosaures dire si oui ou non les
dinosaures carnivores étaient
fondamentalement méchant je suis méfiant
et bien entendu impossible quoi qu'on en
dise à la télévision par contre ce qui
semble très clair c'est que les préjugés
sur la cruauté de ces animaux ont
conduit à des interprétations fausse de
certains fossiles etc les gens de
préjugés dont elle était victime
ovi raptor son nom signifie voleur
d'oeuvres ainsi nommé car il fut
découvert pris sur le fait de son
abominable forme père fossilisés pencher
sur un nid qu'il était en train de
piller est toutefois bien des années
après sa découverte on soit rendu compte
que les oeufs dans le nid était soudain
en vire à tort et que le nid en question
était en fait le sien ce soi-disant
voleurs dauphin pitoyable n'était en
fait ni plus ni moins qu'à parents
dévoués qui a couvé sony jusqu'à la mort
pour tenter de le protéger
et en parlant de cruauté savait qu'ils
étaient encore plus cruel que le t-rex 1
à spinoza non tractopelle non à vélo
sirat armé d'un lance-roquettes
cherchant un requin non pas du tout la
réponse c'est trichomonas gallinae mais
c'est quoi ça à pokémon euh non c'est
une maladie qui fait des petits trous
dans la mâchoire et la trachée et qui a
entraîné la mort de pilleurs
tyrannosaures et ces deux maladies
d'oiseaux ah oui d'ailleurs dans
trichomonas gallinae ya galinet qui
n'ont rarement au gallinacé les poules
il n'était pas si terrible que ça après
tout en conclusion de cet homme science
les oiseaux sont apparus au temps des
dinosaures parmi les dinosaures à partir
d'ancêtres dinosaures et ils
appartiennent donc à la famille des
dinosaures exactement de la même manière
que vous êtes vous même de la famille de
votre grand père évidemment c'est facile
de critiquer mais plutôt que de céder à
la caricature facile et aux critiques
sans fondement il convient quand on fait
de la science de laisser de côté nos
préjugés nos a priori et de s'en
remettre aux faits et aux fossiles
la science est un perpétuel progrès et
les représentations et images y compris
dans nos têtes doivent progresser avec
elle il reste néanmoins une dernière
question si les oiseaux qui sont des
dinosaures ont survécu alors les
dinosaures ne se sont pas éteints en
effet mais cela ne veut pas dire que
l'extinction de masse d'il ya 65
millions d'années n'a pas eu lieu
une météorite est bien tombée et de
nombreuses espèces ont disparu dont
beaucoup de dinosaures et même les
oiseaux ayant laissé des plumes
c'est par exemple le cas des sports ni
dont on a parlé tout à l'heure ainsi que
des aînés encore need celle les ancêtres
des oiseaux actuels s'en sont sortis et
finalement certains dinosaures
les oiseaux sont toujours parmi nous
alors oui ils sont très différents des
autres dinosaures mais ils ne le sont
pas moins que ne l'étaient les
dinosaures du trias de ceux du
jurassique ou que celle du jurassique ne
l'était du ce du crétacé les oiseaux ne
sont qu'une forme de dinosaure parmi une
foisonnante diversité d'autres aient
eux-mêmes présente une diversité de
formes et d'écologie formidable et sont
présents depuis les airs jusque dans
l'eau en passant par la terre ferme qui
avec près de dix mille espèces d'oiseaux
connu aujourd'hui contre-appel 5000 de
mammifères une seule espèce humaine
ces patates nous sommes toujours parmi
les dinosaures se stoppe science est
terminé merci de l'avoir suivi en guise
de complément pour tout savoir sur
l'origine des oiseaux
nous vous recommandons la lecture du
chapitre qui y est dédié dans le guide
critique de l'évolution
peut-être avez-vous aussi remarquer que
nous avons essayé autant que possible de
ne placer que des dinosaures découverts
en france pour illustrer la vidéo si ce
n'est pas le cas ça vous fera une bonne
occasion de la revoir
sinon il ya le dinosaure de france par
eric bulteau est sentie plus récemment
le mimo par l'équipe des fouilleurs du
site de dinosaures d'angeac quant à nous
nous vous disons à la prochaine fois et
merci à tous
un peu
j'en ai marre d'avoir toujours raison